[Music]
anthos is Google clouds new open
platform that lets you run an app anyway
simply flexibly and securely with anthos
we bring the cloud to you you will have
heard a lot about kubernetes in the last
few years
I mean it's five years old this year so
why aren't you running under your
company yet maybe you feel that
kubernetes has meant more for startups
or digital companies because not
everyone has the luxury of moving
immediately to the cloud and let's be
clear your company does want to move to
the cloud it's on the long term plan the
reality is your team has faced many
roadblocks you have an on-prem
environment full of legacy systems and
you don't feel ready to make the move to
the cloud some systems can't move to the
cloud for one reason or another due to
regulatory or compliance needs from what
you've learned it seems like running
kubernetes on prim is challenging there
are a multitude of options to run it
including a hundred or so do-it-yourself
methods and the project maintains a fast
release cycle those updates provide
helpful security features but that also
means needing someone to manage and
frequently roll out updates that's like
giving someone a puppy for their
birthday they love it but they'll have
to do a ton of work you want to care
about keeping services up and
operational and making sure there are no
security incidents while your developers
think about binaries and containers as
an operator you are concerned about SaaS
and users you're worried if you make it
too easy to run things your developers
could choose to run anything risking D
standardization as an administrator you
need to be able to dictate policies and
decide which apps to talk to which
network endpoints for example requiring
applications to be signed to run and
then on top of that you want
observability of your applications and
services this is where gke on-prem comes
into play and lets you take advantage of
kubernetes and cloud technology in your
data center the creators of communities
have built an enterprise-grade
environment with life cycle and upgrades
managed by Google engineers gke on-prem
installs into your existing vSphere
environment you create a cluster and
then you can run the entire ecosystem of
kubernetes tools with it you can manage
the applications you deploy to your GK
on-prem environment using the Google
Cloud console that you use for cloud
workloads
giving you unified management this also
means when you are ready to move to a
hybrid architecture you can very easily
move your applications to the same
platform running in the cloud using gke
on Google Cloud when you choose Google
we give you a solution that lets you
adopt communities and its many benefits
without necessarily having to move
immediately to the public cloud you will
enjoy faster time-to-market lower
administrative overhead and increased
innovation plus you have consistent
management of applications deployed and
gke on Google cloud you get Best of
Breed tools built for how Google runs
services based on the sto service mesh
and stack driver by thinking services
first you can automate policy and
security at scale at a higher layer in
the stack enabling greater awareness
consistency and control at the
application level not at the container
level and finally you get access to all
the modern tooling for DevOps and sre on
top of the kubernetes platform and easy
deployment of popular applications from
the GCP marketplace with GK and GK on
Prem you can overcome the trade-offs
once faced with hybrid approaches to the
cloud you get kubernetes managed by its
creators at Google and you can dedicate
more time to serving your own customers
to learn more about Cuba news and gke
please subscribe to our Channel
you